violet punch dans vous allez bien pour
cette vidéo je suis très content j'ai un
sponsor
quand je pense à la dernière vidéo par
exemple sur les masques a été démonétisé
interdite aux moins de 18 ans voilà donc
c'est hyper cool lors des sponsors et je
les remercie c'est une boîte qui
s'appelle fiber et en plus ça fait super
plaisir parce que leurs produits
j'utilise à titre personnel depuis
plusieurs années déjà
alors fiber j'en avais déjà peut-être
entendu parler c'est un site internet
qui met en relation des gens comme vous
et moi avec des freelances et je m'en
suis servi déjà plusieurs fois par
exemple quand j'ai besoin de faire des
sous titres sur des vidéos
j'étais sonné bâle par exemple je les
fais via fader corps plus récemment
toute machine twitch genre les badges
l'overlay etc
je les fais via fader aussi et
personnellement j'ai bien non servir
quand j'ai pas mal de budget je sais
exactement ce que je veux et m'a demandé
au bea précise je trouve que ça colle
hyper bien avec pfizer
mais on peut s'en servir pour plein
d'autres trucs aussi je mets plein
d'infos en descriptions notamment ce
qu'ils ont fait pour moi toute ma chaîne
twitch je vais vraiment découvrir le
site il ya plein de services différents
et il y en a vraiment pour tous les
budgets pour tous les goûts etc
et voilà je le remercie encore une fois
de se montrer cette vidéo on y va il ya
plus d'un mois
c'était en juillet j'ai déconnecté des
réseaux sociaux pendant 30 jours
alors pour être plus précis j'ai
déconnecté de facebook nachat instagram
twitter facebook messenger aussi et j'ai
gardé youtube et twitch parce que dans
mon usage s'est pas vraiment des réseaux
sociaux et déjà rien qu'en enlevant
instagram et twitter il s'est passé des
choses intéressantes pendant ces 30
jours donc voilà dans cette vidéo on va
parler de mon expérience de ce que ça
m'a appris de ce que j'en ai tiré et
peut-être même que ça va vous donner
envie de le faire alors je vais pas vous
faire un speech en amont de l'expérience
sur les problèmes liés aux réseaux
sociaux
c'est tout ce dont j'ai déjà parlé
plusieurs fois pardon je fais une vidéo
sur l'addiction aux smartphones va en
gros les les principes d'addiction
smartphone s'est sensiblement les mêmes
au niveau de l'addiction aux réseaux
sociaux clair je m'arrête de seconde sur
le mot addiction qui est assez
controversé en fait sur cette
problématique de smartphones beaucoup de
gens préfèrent parler de problèmes
comportementaux plutôt qu'à diction je
vous mets des des ressources en
descriptions il ya aussi cette vidéo sur
l'impact générationnel que j'avais fait
dans laquelle on parle de l' isolement
de l'estimé de soi ce genre de choses
voilà je pars revenir en détail sur tout
ça mais ce que je vais vous dire dans
cette vidéo c'est pas forcément pourquoi
c'est mal c'est bien etc
et c'est plutôt vous
mon ressenti lors de l'arrêt de ces 30
jours parce que chez moi c'est à un vrai
problème ça quand je passais vraiment en
cumulé des heures par jour sur instagram
twitter facebook messenger
c'est assez difficile à définir mais en
gros sur ces 30 jours et ça va ou
surprendre je me suis senti plus en plus
lucides plus présents devant ce truc de
présence et quelque part c'est un peu
bizarre de dire ça mais toujours plus
authentique en fait ça m'a rappelé un
truc quand j'avais vu le dernier épisode
de game of thrones
je m'étais coupé des réseaux sociaux
jeux pas que c'était pour éviter les
spoilers et tout est donc j'avais vu
l'épisode je m'étais vraiment fait mon
idée du truc tu vois j'avais bien
réfléchi dessus etc
j'avais mon avis et après je suis allé
sur les réseaux sociaux et j'ai
découvert la vie des autres moi
l'épisode je l'avais qui fait foyer
jours les gens ils avaient incendié les
scénaristes mais vu que j'avais mon
opinion avant de me confronter à celles
des autres je savais ce que je pensais
tu vois et c'était super agréable en
fait comme expérience
en fait j'avais sent que c'est plutôt
rare parce que généralement sur les
réseaux sociaux une information et vient
en même temps qu'une opinion est souvent
cette opinion ou cet avis il est
rarement mesurer quoi donc j'avoue que
sur ces 30 jours je me suis rapproché de
ce que je pensais moi et donc
inévitablement je me suis rapproché de
man u et explore davantage quand tu te
déconnecte de tout ça tu as vraiment ce
truc de penser librement toi et c'est
non seulement important mais en plus
nécessaire je trouve
l'autre élément important c'est le
nombre d'informations qui vient à moi
qui a nettement diminué alors évidemment
j'étais au fait des choses importantes
je continue à lire la presse etc
mais je sais pas il y avait moins des
petits fact des petits scandales des
ragots de l'internet et ou alors ce
serait faux de dire que pendant cette
période
ça va pas manquer ouais si ça m'a un
petit peu manqué mais j'étais quand même
plus apaisée sans savoir et les trucs
vraiment important bah je les avais via
mes potes en irl
donc voila tu rates pas totalement le
truc mettez pas tu vois les yeux rivés
tout temps sur ton téléphone à suivre un
peu un scandale en direct ça j'avoue
c'était cool
de prendre de la distance par rapport à
ce surplus d'informations là vraiment on
n'a pas besoin de savoir tout ça est
l'autre élément qui m'a fait du bien
c'est aussi de m'éloigner de toute la
négativité l'acidité la toxicité qu'on
peut trouver sur twitter par exemple et
là sur ce sexualisation là là sur le sur
esthétisme qu'on peut trouver sur
instagram toi ou genre 90% des trucs que
tu m'as tu ça n'existe pas quoi genre ça
va des meufs et des mecs à genre des
lézards tu vois en ce moment je rase à
mon pote tout pète j'adore regarder des
comptes sur des lézards des serpents et
où les gens parlent avec les chevaux il
y en a ils ont des couleurs de ouf
badie dame et ses peintures et les cas
il pousse la saturation et toute la
jambe même sur les lézards dégâts donc
me détacher de tout ça aussi ça m'a fait
énormément de bien ça m'a vraiment
permis de me recentrer sur l'essentiel
recentrer sur ce que je pense ce que je
ressens des informations importantes ne
pas sûr saturé mon cerveau quoi est le
dernier élément qui m'a fait énormément
de bien
c'est le gain de temps imaginez vous
passer une demi heure par jour sur
instagram une demi heure par jour sur
twitter et une demi heure par jour sur
facebook messenger snapshot hockey et je
sais que parmi vous il y en a c'est
beaucoup plus qu'une demi heure sur
instagram sur twitter ok mais rien que
ces trois là je cumule ça fait une demi
en ligne de mire une demi heure c'était
une heure et demie par jour tu
multiplies sa part 30 jours j'ai
économisé 45 eur enfin économiser je
sais pas mais en tout cas j'ai pas passé
sur les réseaux sociaux 45 heures 45
heure tu te rends compte que ces gens
une semaine de taf c'est une semaine de
taff fois en un mois et au moment où
j'avais arrêté
c'était un des éléments qui me faisait
le plus peur dans le fait de me
reconnecter quoi parce que au début
quand j'ai commencé à des connexions
mais vraiment j'avais une mémoire genre
musculaire machinal ou jouvray
d'instinct toi j'avais un moment pas
front téléphone tac tac tac de twitter
ouah au jeu j'enlève l'appui évidemment
bien j'ai supprimé les habits quoi je me
suis dit ok tu étais pas capable en fait
tu vois genre il faut vraiment forcer
ton cerveau à ne pas y aller donc c'est
quoi on va supprimer les applis ça va
être plus simple et c'est ce que j'ai
fait par contre je m'attendais à un plus
gros manque que ça il ya eu un manque
n'étaient pas amants que viscéral
tu vois c'était pas un truc genre put a
ring faut ma dose quoi il faut ma dose
pas du tout alors du coup pourquoi ne
pas continuer pourquoi revenir sur le
réseau bah déjà ça paraît évident mais
c'est mon métier il ya un an
ça me rendait où vous voulez avoir un
métier où je veux vraiment j'étais
dissocier de tout ça vraiment j'essaie
de trouver des pistes dans ma tête genre
en quoi je peux me reconvertir pour être
loin des réseaux bon j'ai accepté j'ai
accepté que ça fait partie de mon
quotidien
mais j'ai obligé d'y être là sur les 30
jours de juillet j'ai relayé aucune de
mes vidéos par exemple sur instagram ou
twitter etc
pareil si j'avais eu des posts
sponsorisés affaire j'aurais pas pu les
faire et donc j'aurais pu passer à côté
d'opportunités commerciales par exemple
et c'est mon job
donc c'est assez embêtant l'autre
élément c'est que j'ai besoin de parler
aux gens alors pour les potes c'est
différent parce que les potes quand tu
lis sur les réseaux hta une mini news
tous les jours et donc du coup tu as
l'impression de de savoir comment ils
vont de connaître leur life etc
alors que pas du tout donc là le fait
d'être hors des réseaux ben il ya bien
certains potes tu vois je t'ai l'agent
[ __ ] ça fait longtemps que pas une
nouvelle de ce gala jean van hamme sage
ouais comment ça va devoir vraie prise
de nouvelles et incertain où jean
renoncé à appeler on a parlé hyper
longtemps c'est un groupe sharepoint et
c'est un truc que je n'aurais jamais
fait je pense si j'avais été encore sur
les réseaux sur une fois le montage de
la vidéo et ça me fait mal ce passage on
a l'impression que le mec découvre le
téléphone et les conversations
téléphoniques avec ses potes on est des
gens temps c'est dingue
on s'est parlé au téléphone du coup je
sais pas si c'est clair mais je parle
évidemment pas des potes proche qu'on
appelle souvent je parle de ces autres
potes on a l'impression de connaître
leur vie alors qu en fait pas du tout
vous voyez très bien de qui je parlais
mais là je parle pas des gens que je
connais quand vous dis que j'ai besoin
de parler aux gens où j'ai besoin voilà
de gemmes trans à fourmies en fait c'est
comme ouvrir la fenêtre et voir les gens
ils sont sur les terrasses et discute
les gens marchent et cetera
il ya un truc où j'aime l'effervescence
j'avoue beaucoup moins depuis que vide
pas se mentir
tu as l'impression de faire partie d'un
tout en fait et d'ailleurs anecdote au
tout début de mon expérience au jus en
juillet il ya eu donc ce qui s'est passé
avec georges floyd il ya eu le hashtag
blacklight batteur qui a été relayé en
puissance et caetera et je sais pas si
vous avez vu mais a beaucoup beaucoup de
gens qui ont posté un poste tout noir
dans un carré noir sur instagram
mais j'aime vraiment j'ai l'impression
que tout le monde l'a fait j'aurais moi
j'ai des potes qui montraient leur fidh
c'était genre tout le monde le post est
le truc par mois tu vois alors
évidemment il ya plein de manières de
soutenir cette cause là tu vas et tu
fais pas un poste a dû faire d'autres
choses tu vois moi j'ai fait des choses
de mon côté mais tout ce que je faisais
bah je pouvais pas communiqué dessus
donc c'est à dire que si quelqu'un et
c'est pas grave aurait pour moi je mange
je m'en fous d'accord mais ce que je
veux dire ce que quelqu'un qui est dans
cette ambiance là tu vois qui va sur les
comptes d'autres youtuber etc qui voit
ça et qui va sur mon compte mais il se
dit ok si russie s'en bat les steaks
donc ça c'était un petit peu bizarre
quoi quand il y avait tout ça est où
j'étais un peu là genre bah je soutiens
mais je ne peux pas à l'exprimer
comme vous et ça me permet d'aborder un
dernier point qui pour moi est important
qui fait que c'est pour ça que je quitte
pas aussi les réseaux sociaux c'est que
ça me permet de questionner la société
c'est quelque chose que je fais beaucoup
sur ma chaîne youtube mais que je peux
aussi beaucoup en dehors là je suis
comme ça j'aime beaucoup réfléchir
questionner la société et c est pour ça
tu as besoin d'être sur les réseaux
parce que tu as beaucoup de mouvements
beaucoup de penser beaucoup d'idées et
c'est qui qui se reflète dans les
réseaux qui sont discutés sur les
réseaux basse et été témoin de beaucoup
de choses en fait quand tu es sur les
réseaux les changements sociétaux les
changements d'habitude nos craintes nous
envient bref plein de trucs donc la
question sait pas comment arrêter les
réseaux sociaux tu vois pas ce que j'en
ai pas envie et je pense que beaucoup
d'entre vous n'ont plus la question sait
plus ce qu'est ce qu'il faut changer
dans sa relation aux réseaux sociaux
pour que ça reste un plaisir
alors j'avais commencé à y réfléchir et
que certains d'entre vous quand j'écris
cette vidéo sur twitch et ça m'a rappelé
un livre de 2018 de cale newport qui
s'appelle digital minimalisme dans ce
livre il parle de l'importance de
commencer par trente jours de détox
d'une certaine manière pour questionner
son usage
c'est l'occasion aussi de réfléchir à ce
que les technologies nous apporte
et comment elles peuvent servir nos
intérêts et aussi réfléchir à ce que
c'est nos intérêts en fait ok je sais
que c'est quoi qu'on aimerait c'est
crois qu'on attend de la vie très grosse
question très très grosse question et
j'avoue que moi le fait de commencer par
ces 30 jours de manière assez brutale ça
m'a beaucoup aidé et je pense que si
j'avais mis juste un bloqueur de temps
par exemple sur twitter et instagram da
aurait pas du tout eu le même impact
j'aurais été juste dans un truc de
frustration qui n'aurait pas été la même
chose je pense que ces 30 jours ils
doivent aboutir à une augmentation de
votre intentionnalité
genre qu'est ce que j'attends de ces
réseaux est quelque part adopté une
relation de méfiance en fait vis-à-vis
de 5 en un mois où j'ai repris mon usage
etc
je vois que très vite tu retombes en
fait dans les vortex tu retombes dans
des gouffres
c'est très très facile en fait ils sont
très bien faites ces applis mais quand
tu conscientise tout ça quand tu te
rends compte voilà que ce que céline
fini de scrolling par exemple comment
l'appli est fait en sorte que je reste
le plus longtemps possible et c'est un
peu comme ce qu'on avait vu avec
l'épisode sur le smartphone enfin ça
t'aide ça t'aide à prendre du recul
comme par exemple le fait que pour
rafraîchir un fil d'actualité il faut le
tirer vers le bas comme ça est lâché et
un peu ce côté genre machines à sous tu
vois c'est les mêmes principes
en fait et d'ailleurs en parlant de fil
d'actualité une manière aussi
qui peut vous permettre de gagner du
temps il ya plein d'extension qui existe
en fait qui supprime les fid d'actualité
par exemple sur facebook il ya
l'extension chrome c'est newsfeed
éradiquer à tort et ça supprime ton fidh
facebook donc du coup tu utilise
facebook que pour la messagerie et pour
les événements par exemple j'ai piqué
les équivalents sur twitter et/ou et
j'imagine qu'à d'autres équivalent pour
deux plateformes aussi donc voilà je
sais de pas baisser la garde et j'espère
que cette vidéo va vous donner envie d
c'est à votre tour et je suis hyper
curieux si vous essayez d'avoir vos
retours en commentaire je profite de
cette vidéo pour vous inviter à suivre
ma newsletter newsletter moi ce que je
kiffe là dedans c'est que voilà c'est
hors des réseaux sociaux juste vous
recevez un email
et vous avez une information de la part
qu est-ce qui a dansé newsletters c'est
la question qui se suit un j'imagine je
pense à des fois ça peut être des choses
très intimes comme par exemple cette
news et après j'ai passé quatre cent
mille abonnés je vous expliquer pourquoi
la fois j'étais fier est à la fois pas
du tout et et toutes les frustrations
que ça peut entraîner en fait de passer
ce genre de palier et tout mais ça peut
aussi être genre des recommandations
d'articles de vidéos etc où ça peut être
aussi quand je sors quelque chose par
exemple quand j'avais sorti le podcast
du meilleur podcast j'ai fait newsletter
voilà donc j'espère donc que cette vidéo
vous a plu si vous essayez ces 30 jours
sans réseaux sociaux bah dites moi
comment ça s'est passé pour vous et
je suis sûr je suis sûr que vous allez
kiffer mais vous le savez déjà de façon
pendant que je vous ai même pas dit au
revoir donc la crise ciao et merci
encore une fois à faveur d'autres comme
lorsqu'on choisit cette vidéo merci